en su época de esplendor en tourette's
había siete minas activas hoy sólo hay
dos y los símbolos soviéticos que antes
llevaban con orgullo ahora son retirados
supongo que no pudieron quitarlos
cuando un tipo va a trabajar no miras el
letrero de la urss estalló no piensa
funciona la mina hoy
y funcionará mañana
esta mina estaba en la calle lenin que
ahora se llama calle de la historia lo
cual le parece irónico a este antiguo
minero
creo que no se puede reescribir la
historia hubo gente que ha construido
este país y lenin fue uno de ellos los
camaradas de ucrania deberían valorar y
respetar el antiguo líder
la nostalgia comunista es común en
toretes ciudad que no ha prosperado
precisamente desde 1991 pero la política
del gobierno democráticamente elegido de
ucrania es explícitamente no respetar a
los líderes bolcheviques una ley
aprobada en 2015 los colocó en la misma
categoría que a los nazis todas las
calles y ciudades que tuvieran sus
nombres fueron renombradas
sports cubas de conformidad con la ley
ucraniana sobre la condena de los
regímenes totalitarios comunistas y
nacional socialistas o nazis
tratar la prohibición de la propagación
de los símbolos
perkins pasa a llamarse torres de
doctores con mis curado tar shinsky fue
nombrada así en honor a félix
dzerzhinski pero incluso el archivista
parece no tener claro quién era
exactamente este personaje una persona
lo llamaban iron félix
bueno imagino que era una de sus
características la dureza
aquí tuve
félix dzerzhinski fue el fundador de la
policía secreta comunista que asesinó a
millones de ciudadanos soviéticos
los rusos derribaron su estatua en moscú
hace 30 años la de torres no fue
retirada sino hasta 2015
andrew keen una activista local habla de
lo poco que la gente sabía sobre este
hombre y
una chica dijo que era un general ruso
una mujer dijo que era un hombre de
estado soviético
que cuidaba de los niños
y eso demostró que la gente no conoce su
historia
pero para andrés el hecho de que la
gente entienda o apruebe la política de
descolonización es en realidad algo
secundario
hay símbolos del totalitarismo estatuas
de personas que torturaron y mataron a
millones de sus propios ciudadanos
provocaron hambrunas
enviaron a la gente a pudrirse en los
campos
deberíamos haber esperado unos años más
o debatir si eran realmente buenos y
dejarlos en su sitio claro que no creo
que todo se hizo de forma absolutamente
correcta
un kremlin autoritario sigue intentando
dominar ucrania cuyo ejército se
enfrenta a las fuerzas rusas a sólo 7
kilómetros de aquí muchos ucranianos
beldades comunicación como un paso clave
en la emancipación del país para otros
sin embargo no es más que una fachada la
planta de tratamiento de carbón antes se
llamaba será since cap ahora se llama
servín iscar
por esto es sobre todo una ciudad minera
en una región donde la industria de
carbón está en crisis a los habitantes
gustaría que cambiaran las cosas más
allá de los nombres de sus ciudades y
sus calles
deberían plantar árboles o poner postes
de luz para que la gente no tenga que
caminar en la oscuridad entonces la
calle sería diferente entonces podrían
cambiar el nombre y la gente lo
entendería sería elegante si no es así
que sacamos de esto nada nada ha
cambiado la vida en este pueblo es la
misma verdad la misma de siempre
las autoridades de la ciudad insisten en
que las cosas están cambiando
destaca en esta escuela que está siendo
reformada en su interior actualmente los
alumnos si aprenden sobre los crímenes
soviéticos
hoy comenzamos un nuevo tema hablaremos
de los sucesos de los años 20 y 30
el plan de estudios incluye temas
relacionados con los crímenes del
régimen de stalin incluso hay un módulo
específico llamado represiones de masas
si sería extraño estudiar estos temas en
una ciudad que lleva el nombre de un
criminal solo la chica tiene decenas
sino cientos de miles de víctimas en su
conciencia la gente fue asesinada a
tiros o enviada a campos de prisioneros
y todo eso solo pudo hacerse bajo las
órdenes personales de estar shinsky que
dirigía la organización declaró que la
ciudad no podía llevar su nombre
hoy el museo de la escuela celebra
diferentes épocas a los mineros locales
que ayudaron a mitigar los efectos del
desastre de chernóbil y a los soldados
que han muerto en la guerra actual